ah oui il ya un truc que tu sais pas
c'est nous on a listé mystère mystère et
penser
chez moitié français moitié quand je
suis corse ont porté leur nom je sais
que 75% cancer que ma mère c'est quoi
ton papa le foot il est à 10h10 à
décoller il est assez lent genre
bouchehr est toujours 43 ans dix siècles
ont fait la france
tran et demi en sentant l'année faut il
arrêter à tout geek un sans faute au sol
sont républicains qui a réduit l'écart
dans l'argot que fait l'armée n'a pas
brillé mais vu pourquoi est ce que j
l'évier drouot où et masqués ont aidé
yann maillet -3 et rachiki parce que
c'est la corse et en droits et en droit
de stationner ouais parce que la légion
étrangère à l'ap avoir stationné sur une
saillie sur la métropole sauve encore
comme elle est
donc ça chauffe et j'allais vous allez
me wade rythme méchamment trouver des
défauts techniques
au coeur de cette 2e régiment étranger
parachutiste
tu fais quoi comme sport la marche
actionne un appartement ouais c'est
qu'ensuite à bien savoir combien parfois
plus tard prenez l'exemple des idées et
arrêter combien de fois de suite ils
montrent une heure du sud ne s'appelle
plus mauvaise franchise de dire j'ai
choisi le club qui est sûr est que les
chômeurs les brunes et blondes leila
hatami co2 de plus normal mans et de
boire car c'est quand même alors sa 607
que c'est une pure calomnie soleil s'est
jamais arrêté deux ans à l'époque où tu
dois juste mettre quoi pas le bon vin et
quand j'ai commencé c'était
j'avais autant ouais c'est pas moi qui
me voyaient papa maman elle a évolué et
plus deviennent parfois c'est amer alors
nous a fait attendre
il ya quatre cents le kwh à l'autre et
bien tous les dérivés alors voilà c'est
un lot enfin bref j'ai vu à voir ce que
j'attends le maintien quant à la viande
est l'opium du peuple goûteux la série
little walter von chercheur il n'ya pas
voilà c'est à chelsea de roman vrai je
fais honte et de vignes et patrice
abeille vogel s'est bien replacé sur
mamma mia n'a pas cédé aux politiques
alors tu es plus social démocrate
libéral de progrès oui qu'il faut il ya
un truc qui fait cependant l'équipe
était quelqu'un savoir s'il existait un
style en appel le roi ou manger mais peu
importe c'est plutôt royal ascot à ma
chérie
a plutôt eu lieu jeudi en soirée
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont perdu le
pouvoir en 81 [ __ ] n'est ce pas mr des
choses mais c'est tout à fait la nation
la loi la voirie nous sommes en phase
pandémique accord dont s'est toujours
réfugié iphone il faudra les qualités
génial car elle l'image ou alors fait un
cinéma littérature chanson tu as fait
quoi que tout ça part tout cas tout fait
mais c'est un geste anonyme si j'ai les
yeux j'ai pigé représenter le personnel
se sent un parfum de surprendre les gens
au cinéma et à la télé on sait mieux les
mêmes mais ce que tu fais le mieux tout
ça c'est quoi c'est celle et tout ça
instinctivement spontanément d'amour que
les succès que les femmes et par will
jacques davy avait mené jusqu'à le coeur
d'asnières copines ça partout tu peux
deux amphores à safari
nombreuses ici à lire mais j'en ai même
fait combien
il ya pas mal et tu leur racontera quand
ils seront grands ce que tu veux quand
t'es tu es grand en trois ans pourquoi
pas - et si c'était à refaire je
referais exactement la même chose sauf
l'étranger